a guy named ben ryan Metzger put out a
song called Cleveland Indian song rockin
rockin try rocking tribe is that what
it's called these sport songs are
usually pretty cool yeah you like sports
songs there I always get me I with me my
favorite pedana now but only since I
found out about Gary I thought she was
dead she was great they never got rid of
that song how could I mean I still
[ __ ] play kazoo to it they don't
change the end of it they go banana and
i think that the rocking tribe remix
maybe the new anthem got a thousand
eighty eight lights only nine dislike
wow it's pretty impressive folks i'm
gonna give it a maybe it's going to give
it a spin will smash attraction
cleveland ohio we're going all and not
we're rocking baseball uh-huh we're
rocking job and you better be ready to
dig down deep in the game of your life
yeah here we go now swing for the fences
yes you're filled up three lines on
Staffa to the plate and embrace your
daddy yeah Riley together and hold on
tight because we're going for the win
fire up your indian bride we're rocking
baseball uh-huh we're rocking tonight
I'm so better you love it I do yeah it's
not all five we got awful you're
supposed to be redic up dog cream man
you will make it is silly I see bye so
why commitment putting a silly yeah this
is watching this lives in Chicago the
other ones up vote again I love the
armbands those armbands are you I'm an
awesome he's got armbands and he's got
wristbands on too yeah in case he builds
up a sweat it's like Conan O'Brien I'm
sure we can't see him and I'm sure
there's ankle bands there oh yeah oh
yeah he's got the it looks like the
britney spears microphone on yeah with
the hands-free yeah because he's going
he's doing spins the guy can move to
let's be honest yeah i mean it he's won
2 t's but he can move it he's a dancer
yeah that was so ridiculously the singer
dancer i mean yeah i took that as being
silly i didn't see this being arrested
is really committed to him yeah exactly
like Will Smith just offered him again
love to see you i would i would say he's
probably realizing it's a bit silly but
he put a lot of time and effort into
that he wrote a song he choreographed
the dance he's not making it up as he
goes move the furniture out of the
[ __ ] room which is an easy to do I'm
pretty sure he's be serious he's got a
hundred and two thousand followers on
Twitter like he's a legit yeah we also
had the shoes that your vase war in the
original office I didn't think you could
get heels like that he still fight him
holy [ __ ] this is another video oh boy
he's got ankle bands on sweta look at
Ron Paul's got ankle vans on knee pads
too yeah that that's needed in that
[ __ ] room I have no hope and no dream
this guy's a performance artist it's the
same dance though hey Dan but he's got
to I hate to say fluidity oh yeah I
admire there's a flow there
it really is the exact same dance it's
just a guy spinning around yeah let's
see you spin and doing ballet moves I
think he's great to work in a place
without indoor air like that he's still
got the [ __ ] window piece right his
dad didn't take it out yet is the thing
it's probably warm in there too please
have it on I don't hear it what a clean
floor though huh oh yeah oh yeah perfect
regular time to go nuts in that [ __ ]
not a scuff mark on it just does the
idea that he would start [ __ ] freaky
clean floor ok great I gotta tell ya I
feel like I think Cleveland should put
that on the big screen for for the game
yeah you know I'd give him his props he
came up with it he certainly did they
did a good job I'll say swing all the
fences in your view what is that for a
little cleaned and like any where's he
where's Hanson Red Sox guys awesome here
we go you think Cleveland has to look at
this like these are our fans this is
look just left Cleveland they're just
happy to have anything good is
somebody's actually billed as the last
white person downtown you speaking truth
right to the blind there will be justice
I still love it I'm looking to make
roadhouse to what I said I star he's
perfect because remember in the 80s no
one could figure out why that dude you
know let this bucket big cup dude bench
like you did Muhammad house I think his
name was go down said think the movie
was named after I would imagine yeah
look at it and you know what this guy
he's wearing tight black t-shirt nope it
stings how long he's got the area laughs
shudders endless it just keeps going
yeah I don't know you don't like this as
much as the World Series oh no he's too
well built this guy to dance put the
World Series song back on Adrian I think
I think we can make a gym feel a little
better without God rocket tribe is the
name of it you still like this we're
rocking not as much as other ones i am
thinks it's lost its luster this would
have been better if people to put it out
in june not october these guys been
there since day one right now you look
like a bandwagon jumper it's very acidic
Cubs fan though so I want to see the
cubbies pull it out turn it down a
little bit when did you become a Cubs
fan [ __ ] what is [ __ ] me when did you
become a Cubs fan yeah you know while
ago I don't think so cubbies I don't
think so go cubbies the Ivy wall out
there on I town oh you know you're shady
city Windy City ma why you're selling a
local yeah yeah you sit down a a deep
dish a little watch the cubbies play
ball is that what they call eating deep
dish pizza deep dish until they deep
dish oh and realize yeah you guys want
to go in deep dish tonight yeah let's go
deep dish and check out some cubbies
over the Ivy wall what they say yeah